hello and welcome to this video playing
our teacher black and don't want to play
interesting lines it puts some reason
again you get that so often three I
think it's just surprising that them and
there's such a low and new interest in
the main lines that I really just don't
ya get into interesting play there's
nothing particularly wrong with the
London system I'm not saying that just
I'm surprised how often you get that
yeah this is this particular line I've
had on the board more than once let's
check this for a moment though yeah
right it's clear that I'm losing some
stuff just wonder how exactly i should
play together good eggs in context is
not ridiculous but okay i'm going to set
the exchange this is a this is certainly
theoretically explored I don't know
exactly how it is played down Queenie
seven takes Queen III
I'm sure now Queen g6 takes it takes on
g2 there's Queen f3
wow that's really it's strange all that
I don't quite understand what's going on
down what what's the problem okay i was
just playing the main line and i don't
think you should suppose you're supposed
to do with an exchange there I mean I
don't know maybe I have compensation but
it's not this isn't supposed to happen
normally
yeah so he will play some g for business
[Music]
and you can always shoot for buildings
made here take here takes you three
that's easy to miss it's in canvas
that's what I can camp remove red no
it's nice I totally fight horizontally
forgot the theory there I know I don't
think I'm supposed to to use an exchange
them chatter we resigned because of the
checkmate funny meet here with the two
bishops easy to miss and i think
actually i had a railroad to the end and
saying i was thinking i should be fine
so we are here here yeah I'm winning but
I mean this is a basically the threat is
extremely strong but I mean kind of this
is whole this is this so what am I
supposed to do I supposed to do this and
then take with this okay yeah that's not
exactly rocket science why didn't I do
that so that is the refutation of this
stuff yeah I get again material I mean
that cancels Queen takes or Bishop takes
change is king here yeah I've got FF two
pawns and fantastic Bishop Bishop am
normally this is not plate like that
they usually play in play differently
and
okay so the way I played it I think it
should not be enough stock which gives
wide 0.8 that seems about fatso and it's
not zero compensation but it is
definitely not enough so we have three
yeah king of two is just bet I am the
bishop wand III is a bit of an annoyance
for wide yeah so this is not an easy win
like what the engine gives you this kind
of position because the night on d2 will
never get a good square Knight f3 always
I have six and the bishop will come here
and the night goes away and it's that's
not easy at all and this is filled this
feels dangerous we are playing for the
trick all ready and here he is it is
over already check okay good to know the
motives the Borden's mages this is
called checkmate that's why one of my
favorite favorite mates ok guys thanks
for watching